"Frasier" was one of the most successful sitcoms
of the last 30 years, turning its talented cast
into pop culture icons. Now Dr. Crane and
company are going back on the air. Here's
what the cast has been up to since the original
series ended, and who's coming back for round two.
The titular role of Dr. Frasier Crane, the
scholarly psychiatrist and host of "The Dr.
Frasier Crane Show," is played by Kelsey Grammer.
His most iconic role to date, Grammer played
Frasier for a total of 20 years including his time
on "Cheers." In a 2022 interview with Yahoo! News,
when discussing his upcoming reprisal of
the role which made him a household name,
Grammer described the character as, quote,
"like putting on a favorite old jacket."
Since hanging up that uptight old jacket,
Grammer has worked prolifically in Hollywood
as both actor and producer. Immediately following
the end of "Frasier," Grammer played Mr. Skibness
in the Tenney Fairchild film, "The Good Humor
Man." In 2008, he starred as President Andrew
Boone in the comedic political drama,
"Swing Vote," alongside Kevin Costner,
and he also appeared as himself in a handful
of episodes of the NBC comedy, "30 Rock."
"One rule - anybody gets hurt during the
score, we leave them behind to die. Now,
who are you and what are we doing?"
Grammer would also dip his toe into the
blockbuster waters in 2006, starring as
Beast in "X-Men: The Last Stand", returning to
the franchise in an uncredited cameo in "X-Men:
Days of Future Past" and playing Harold Attinger
in "Transformers: Age of Extinction." Grammer also
continues to provide the voice for Sideshow Bob in
"The Simpsons," which he first began in 1990. He
has several projects in production or development
besides the new "Frasier," with his latest
project as of this video including a role in the
historical religious drama, "Jesus Revolution."
It might surprise fans of Martin Frasier's
live-in caretaker, Daphne Moon, to learn
that British actress Jane Leeves almost didn't
land the role. According to Showbiz Cheat Sheet,
the production team had originally sought
out Rosie Perez for the role. Looking back
on Leeves' 263 episodes now, it seems ridiculous
to think that anybody else was ever considered for
the role of Daphne, a performance that
earned her an Emmy nomination in 1993.
After "Frasier" came to an end in 2004, Leeves
took a two-year break from acting before returning
to provide the voice of Eenie in "Garfield: A
Tale of Two Kitties." She worked regularly in
television for several years, appearing in
shows like "Misconceptions" and "Desperate
Housewives" and doing voiceover work for the
animated children's show, "Phineas and Ferb."
In 2010, Leeves landed the role of Joy Scroggs in
the TV Land sitcom, "Hot in Cleveland," which she
played for five seasons. Leeves also starred
as Kit Voss in the Fox medical drama, "The
Resident," which concluded its sixth season in
January 2023 before being canceled months later.
In 2021, Leeves told the Independent that
she wouldn't leave the show to join the
Frasier revival, but now that the show is
over, maybe she found the time to join in.
Frasier's cold-hearted younger brother, Dr.
Niles Crane, is played by David Hyde Pierce.
He won four Emmys for his performance,
only one fewer than Grammer, and was an
integral part of the show's main cast.
Unfortunately for fans of Niles, Yahoo!
News reported that the actor wasn't interested
in reprising his role in the upcoming reboot.
After "Frasier," Hyde Pierce worked regularly in
theater. He played Sir Robin in the Monty Python
musical, "Spamalot," from 2005-2006 and was
nominated for a Tony award for his performance
as Horace Vandergelder in the 2017 revival of
"Hello, Dolly!" Hyde Pierce has also continued
to work in film and television. In 2010 he
starred in the comedic crime thriller, "The
Perfect Host," and in 2017, he reprised his role
as Professor Henry Neumann in the TV miniseries,
"Wet Hot American Summer: First Day of Camp."
He also played Frank Prady in Season 6 of "The
Good Wife," and lent his voice to an episode
of "Sesame Street," as well as voicing Cecil,
the brother of Grammer's Sideshow Bob
in three episodes of "The Simpsons."
"But you'll find one gets more
respect as a humble civil servant,
than as a homicidal maniac
- or as a clown's sidekick."
Hyde Pierce returned to television in
2022 to play Julia Child's wife, Paul,
in the HBO Max series, "Julia." He is also set to
star as Father Conor in the upcoming horror film,
"The Georgetown Project" which is
slated for release sometime in 2023.
The producer of Frasier's radio show, Roz
Doyle, is played by Peri Gilpin. Encouraged
by her parents to pursue her passion for acting
since she was a child growing up in Dallas,
Gilpin studied acting at the University
of Texas and the British American Dramatic
Academy in London. According to Ability
Magazine, she performed on stage in New
York before relocating to Los Angeles
and landing her big break on "Frasier."
Gilpin is still working regularly on television.
Following the end of "Frasier," Gilpin popped up
in shows like "Medium," "Desperate Housewives,"
and Law & Order: Criminal Intent," and lent her
vocal talents to the animated comedy, "King
of the Hill." In 2011, Gilpin had an on-screen
reunion with her "Frasier" co-star Jane Leeves
in an episode of "Hot in Cleveland." Arguably
her biggest TV role since "Frasier" was as
Kim Keeler in the ABC sports drama, "Make It
or Break It," which ran for four seasons. Gilpin
also appeared in a 2017 episode of "Broad City."
In later years, Gilpin has been working
more on the big screen with smaller roles
in movies like "Occupy, Texas," "Flock
of Dudes," and "The Outdoorsman." Recent
roles include the romantic comedy, "We Broke
Up," playing Mrs. Donahue in "Rushed," and
Sara Hughes in the historical drama, "The
Anthrax Attacks." According to Deadline,
she's back on board for the Frasier
revival in a recurring role.
The role of Martin, the Crane
brothers' retired-cop father,
was played by the late John Mahoney. For his
performance, Mahoney was nominated for two
Primetime Emmys in 1999 and 2003. Mahoney's
long career began in 1981 and spanned nearly
four decades before he passed away in 2018
at 77. Despite his success in Hollywood,
he seemed to prefer living in
Chicago and performing on the stage.
"I just want to be back home, and I want
to be on stage and um, where I enjoy it."
After his role in "Frasier," Mahoney
provided the voice of Papi in "Kronk's
New Groove" and appeared in a
2006 episode of "ER." In 2007,
he landed a major film role as Poppy
in the Steve Carell romantic comedy,
"Dan in Real Life," and lent his voice to a Season
19 episode of "The Simpsons." The following year,
Mahoney appeared in the first season of "In
Treatment" and featured in two episodes of the USA
action drama, "Burn Notice." In 2011, he joined
the cast of the "Frasier" cast magnet, "Hot in
Cleveland," and his final performance before his
passing was in a 2015 episode of "Foyle's War."
Martin's loveable canine companion Eddie was
played by an adorable four-legged thespian by
the name of Moose. He's appeared in most
episodes besides the five members of the
main cast — a total of 163 episodes across ten
seasons. Frasier is often at odds with Eddie,
taking umbrage with his propensity to stare
fixedly at him for prolonged periods of time.
"I said down. Good boy Eddie, just get down.
Goo-googood Eddie. Get down - GET DOWN!"
During his distinguished 10-year career, this
diminutive Jack Russel terrier logged four
acting credits. "Frasier" was his small screen
debut, but after his first season on the air,
he immediately booked a job in an episode of "The
5 Mrs. Buchanans" as Petey. The following year,
he played Monte in an episode of
the comedy, "High Society." In 2000,
Moose made the jump to Hollywood, starring
as the titular dog in the film. "My Dog
Skip," which also featured a performance by
his son, Enzo. "Frasier" was Moose's last
onscreen performance before he passed away in
2006 at the ripe old age of 112 in dog years.
Frasier isn't the only colorful personality
at Seattle's KACL radio station. Following the
psychiatrist's time slot is the "Gonzo Sports
Show," and its host, the macho, womanizing Bob
"Bulldog" Briscoe, played by Dan Butler. Butler
popped up in 53 episodes of "Frasier" beginning
in its first season, and it wasn't immediately
clear if he's coming back for the revival.
After his final appearance in 2004, Butler
stayed active in the television industry,
continuing to lend his voice to "Hey
Arnold!" on Nickelodeon as several
characters including Mr. Simmons, and
appearing in episodes of "Quintuplets"
and "Dr. Vegas." He's popped up on
several popular shows since then,
including one-episode roles in "Malcolm in the
Middle," "Supernatural," "House," and "Monk."
In 2011, he returned to the big screen, appearing
as Steve Carell's boss in the romantic comedy,
"Crazy, Stupid Love." In 2020, Butler played
Dr. Alan Mendelson in the romantic drama,
"All My Life," and in 2022, he was featured
in the Marilyn Monroe biopic, "Blonde."
Another KACL personality, restaurant critic Gil
Chesterton is a recurring character throughout
the show's 11-season run. He is played by Royal
Academy of Dramatic Art alum Edward Hibbert. He
appeared in a total of 29 episodes, including
an appearance in the series finale in 2004.
Hibbert has worked steadily since the end
of "Frasier." After the series concluded,
he played Sir Michael Strickland in
the romantic thriller, "A Different
Loyalty." In 2006, he was featured
in the Christopher Nolan thriller,
"The Prestige" and appeared as Randall
Farber in an episode of "Gilmore Girls."
Much like several of his "Frasier" co-stars, he
also appeared in an episode of "Hot in Cleveland"
in 2014. In 2018, Hibbert also provided the
voice of a talking parrot umbrella in "Mary
Poppins Returns" and was featured in episodes of
"Grace and Frankie" and "Blue Bloods" in 2019.
KACL's technical assistant Noel Shempsky, is
played by television journeyman Patrick Kerr.
First introduced in Season 1, Kerr would star
in a total of 22 episodes over the 11 seasons.
"I have a secret weapon. I can
faint at will. Check it out."
After "Frasier," Kerr appeared in an episode of
the much less successful sitcom spinoff series,
"Joey." He followed that up with a
small role in the 2005 action biopic,
"Domino" as a DMV manager, and the following
year appeared in an episode of the CBS sitcom,
"The New Adventures of Old Christine." Over
the next decade, he had several one-episode
roles in shows such as "CSI," "Jessie,"
"Elementary," and "Hannah Montana."
Later film roles include the 2014 comedy,
"Friends and Romans" and 2015's "Anesthesia."
Since then, Kerr has worked in
short films and on episodes of
"Little America" on Apple TV+ and the HBO
Max crime comedy, "Search Party." In 2023,
he appeared as a main cast member in another
Apple TV+ original, "The Big Door Prize."
First appearing in Season 5, KACL's
station manager Kenny Daly is played
by Tom McGowan. He worked primarily in film
before appearing in "Frasier," beginning in
1992 with a role in Michael Mann's historical
drama, "The Last of the Mohicans" and had some
experience in the sitcom world, playing
Bernie in "Everybody Loves Raymond."
Following "Frasier," McGowan stayed busy. In
2004, he had a lead role in the romantic comedy,
"Dog Gone Love." Since then, he's stayed in the
world of television, featuring in shows such
as "Hannah Montana," "Boston Legal," and "CSI."
Unsurprisingly, he also wound up in a 2011 episode
of "Hot in Cleveland" and the following year
he showed up in an episode of "Modern Family."
In 2015, McGowan played Congressman Moyes
in an episode of the HBO political comedy,
"Veep," and returned to the
big screen to play a role in
"Freeheld" alongside Julianne Moore
and Michael Shannon. Two years later,
he had a supporting role as Jax Rindell in
Season 1 of "The Good Fight." His most recent
role was in 2022 when McGowan appeared in an
episode of the NBC comedy, "American Auto."
Daphne Moon's overbearing mother,
Gertrude, who first appears in Season 7,
is portrayed by veteran actress Millicent
Martin. Martin's career began in British
television all the way back in 1957 and
she would make appearances throughout
the remainder of the show, with her
final appearance coming in Season 11.
After her final appearance in "Frasier," Martin
popped up in a 2004 episode of "The Drew Carey
Show" and appeared in "Will & Grace" the
following year. Her television career has
been going strong since then, and she has acted
in episodes of "Chuck," "Castle," "Bones," and
"Modern Family." Not wanting to miss out on the
"Frasier" cast's favorite studio lot hangout spot,
she appeared in two episodes of "Hot in
Cleveland," and appeared in a small role
in the 2017 movie, "The Last Word." In 2017,
McGowan took on the role of Joan-Margaret in
the Netflix original comedy series, "Grace
and Frankie," first appearing in Season 3
and playing the character in 20 episodes to
the show's seventh and final season in 2022.